ready to ring in the New Year in Las
Vegas details for the annual fireworks
and entertainment Extravaganza have just
been unveiled and it is going to be a
night to remember Candace Charles
joining us live from Fashion Show with
what you can expect heading to the strip
this New Year's Eve it is how we do it
here Candace
that's right Heather this year's Dean is
a let's go big and that's exactly what
it's going to be as the the sky above
the Las Vegas Strip a light sub as we
get ready to ring in the New Year
America's party is returning bigger than
ever fireworks will be launched from
eight rooftop locations including MGM
Grand Caesar's Palace and the Strat then
the entertainment Extravaganza will go
off in classic Las Vegas style as we
shout three two one the show was brought
to you by Las Vegas events and the Las
Vegas Convention a visitors Authority
and of course fireworks breaker rucci it
will feature a soundtrack that will put
you in the mood starting with the voice
of Mariah Carey the night culminates
with a synchronized countdown taking
place at Resorts World where Tiesto will
be performing putting this together
though is no swell fee guys it takes
five days to install 66 pyro technicians
and nearly 4 000 hours of hard work now
they've been planning for about 12
months for eight minutes of thrilling
and memorable fireworks
just like every other year only better
thousands will venture onto Las Vegas
strip just outside these doors and take
it all in when fireworks by Gucci
launches its fireworks show
[Music]
now mcdriver usually bring again 300 000
people to the strip but if you want to
stay at home that's okay all you gotta
do is walk out your doors and look up
and of course we got you covered with
all the details on our website
8newsnow.com for now live from the
fashion show mall I'm Candace Charles
Aiden is now oh Candace that is awesome
so glad and we're glad to have you here
for this New Year's Eve hey Plaza Hotel
also going to be joining in on the New
Year's Eve festivities they're going to
be adding a never-before-seen drone
display to ring in the New Year it'll
have a 150 drones lighting up the sky
downtown with a countdown you can even
be part of their rooftop viewing Party
Disco on their website to get tickets
as Candice mentioned you can join us on
New Year's as we count down 2023 with
fireworks and every time zone Michael Yo
Nikki Novak are Live From The Palms
Resort Casino we're going to be live all
over Las Vegas Candice will be out there
too performances by Casey Donahue Kenny
Loggins Belinda Carlisle the party
starts at 9 00 PM there's going to be a
ball drop in New York at that time and
of course it is all right here on
Channel 8 so you can stay in your
comfies and not have to worry about the
temperature outside Sherry we